welcome back to cbs this morning there
is a major development in the case of
briana taylor
the 26 year old emt was shot and killed
in her home during a louisville police
raid in march
yesterday taylor's mother filed a
request for a new grand jury
and an independent prosecutor to review
her daughter's death
now this follows our exclusive interview
with two grand jurors in the case
they told us that they were never
presented with the option of
deliberating murder or manslaughter
charges
which contradicts statements made by the
kentucky attorney general his name is
daniel cameron
first on cbs this morning ryan nichols
the president of the fraternal order
police chapter that represents the
louisville metro police department
is talking about the investigation he
also responded to what brianna taylor's
boyfriend that's kenneth walker says
unfolded when police raided taylor's
home
a tragedy did in fact happen a police
officer was
critically injured a young woman was
fatally injured
and you know the the long thorough
investigation ensued
and that's the process that should
happen you know there are two sides of
course to every story
but what is not in dispute is that
brianna taylor
is dead that she was killed in a hail of
police gunfire but let's go to kenneth
walker and his
his encounter with police 32 shots fired
that night
after he fired what he said was one
warning shot
not knowing what was happening in his
apartment so i do believe that the
officers were definitely
justified in returning fire 32 shots
ryan
32 shots well in a situation like that
when when you return fire to to stop a
threat
typically you may not be aware
of how many rounds someone else is
firing
how many other officers are firing and
perhaps you may not have an
accurate count of the rounds you fired
in a high stress situation like that
how do you explain the incident report
from the night
that said that there was no forced entry
in the apartment we know that's not true
they said that there were no shots that
were fired when brianna taylor was hit
at least five times
obviously the information had not been
completely filled out in the portion of
the incident report that was released
not by any means suggesting that the
police were saying none of those things
occurred
because it was obvious they had not
being part of that investigation i think
probably the report should not have been
released at that time
you have the attorneys for kenneth
walker claiming cover up
you have the grand jurors who talked to
us a couple of days ago
they covered it up that's what the
evidence that i
saw and i felt like there should have
been
lots more charges i want to get your
response to
their belief that there was a that there
was and is a cover-up
by the louisville police department
about what happened that night
i don't believe there's a cover-up of of
anything
that occurred can i definitely say
affirmatively that no
mistakes on anything were made obviously
not but i don't believe that there was
any type of cover up
and if there was that that would
definitely be found out
by the many entities that are conducting
these investigations
are you comfortable ryan with the grand
jury's findings in the case
i have faith that the attorney general
did a thorough and complete
investigation and has a
competent qualified staff to do that
you're calling attorney general
cameron's investigation a complete and
thorough investigation
other people would disagree with you
about that that's why the more you hear
about this case the more questions are
being raised
do you see that yes ma'am i understand
that there's other
agencies and entities that are still
looking into things from other aspects
of the investigation
if they conclude that
it was a tragic incident that
but nothing illegal happened then
we have to be willing to deal with that
and move forward from that
also you don't believe this has race has
played a role here
at all no i don't think this occurred as
a
as a result of any type of racial
uh issue or that this this was
determined by race somehow
do you think outside of this case that
the louisville police department has a
problem
with racial bias
no i think we're a very diverse
department we try to stay up with the
national best practices
in 2020 45 of the arrests have been
black people but they only make up
23 percent of the louisville population
and you go from that to the tragedies
that occur
how do you explain that well so i don't
have all the specific numbers of
if you're talking shooting tragedies or
anything like that
that we can't agree that there is a
difference in the number when it comes
to
black victims and white victims at the
hand of the police can we at least agree
on that
sure so the circumstances that lead up
to every specific
incident whether it's an
officer-involved shooting here or
anywhere else
you know an investigation occurs how do
you explain how many police officers
do not seem to be held accountable in
these type of incidents
well i would say that once those
investigations occur the police
are and definitely should be held
accountable
but they're not though ryan nichols are
not held accountable
well ma'am if the law here is such that
nothing illegal
occurred on either side of that door
that night and our attorney general
did find some charges to pursue and is
going to
pursue those charges as it relates to
one officer
how is the accountability not occurring
what's the morale of your police
department these days
so morale has is low here they want to
be here
and they don't want citizens to have to
live in fear of violence of any kind
right
and right and so it's very frustrating
it is frustrating an attorney for
sergeant john mattingly also said that
attorney general cameron conducted a
careful thorough investigation
and came to the right decision nichols
said when it comes to change his union
is always interested in fair and
balanced reforms
that enhance policing and officer john
mattingly was the one when
kenneth walker fired the warning shot
the police say that
his his shot hit john mattingly in the
leg uh the ballistics report
seems to say that it's inconclusive but
it is such a
i appreciate ryan nichols taking the
time i thought we had a very good
conversation
never good though when people go ma'am
yeah but but we had a very good
conversation i think
um but you have that story in the news
again this morning from marcellus tennis
where the
the police body camera wasn't activated
and i think
we continue to have this conversation
and people get frustrated on both sides
police are frustrated the community is
frustrated we go round and round and
nothing changes
that's the frustration to the point that
the the two grand jurors uh
made yesterday um they don't believe
that the that the government in in
kentucky's account
exactly you know jobs with what what
they saw exactly and so there there's a
discrepancy there
i'm fascinated by the justifiable use of
force kenneth walker is a legal kentucky
gun owner he
fires one shot 32 come back the union's
saying yeah well
that's how it goes stressful moments
people should vote because criminal law
is written by general assemblies if you
vote and different people are in there
you can change the laws
very good point